now the notion of the holy roman emperor
and the holy roman empire does not last
much beyond charlemagne after his death
over the course of the 9th century his
empire is broken up his successors are
not able to carry on the title but then
we get into the 10th century
as you can see here the empire of
charlemagne has now broken up the west
west frankia starting to resemble modern
day france not quite exactly
and the eastern two-thirds are now under
the control of otto a german king
and because of his ability to offer
protection and frankly just his power he
is crowned holy roman emperor one of the
reasons why this is significant once
again it's saying hey the byzantine
emperor isn't really the heir to the
roman empire it's this holy roman
emperor
but otto is able to create a line of
holy roman emperors that continues all
the way until 1806 when they are
conquered by napoleon bonaparte now the
holy roman empire itself and voltaire
famously said is neither holy nor roman
nor an empire over various stages in its
history is fragmented it's many kingdoms
with different levels of autonomy but
under auto it was quite unified now as
we get into the 11th century the divide
between east and west becomes even more
pronounced
we've already talked about this ongoing
power struggle between west and east
between which bishops have primacy over
christendom we've talked about hey who
is the real heir to the roman empire
we've talked about
latin versus greek we've talked about
the germanic kings having
influence now and really following the
west we've talked about the notion of
philoque
and those aren't all of the issues on
top of that you have this notion of
leavened and unleavened bread
where in the west in their mass when
they are consecrating the bread to be
viewed as the body of christ they used
unleavened bread based on the belief
that this is what christ used during the
last supper in the east they said no we
have agreed to use leavened bread and so
this is one further tension now even
more than the actual issues are the
sense of well why do you think you have
the right to tell me what to do
and as we get into 1053 you have what
are known as the latin churches in
constantinople being shut down by the
patriarch of constantinople patriarch
cerullarius or carularius
saying that hey these guys are going
against what is actually acceptable in
christianity
now in retaliation you have pope leo the
ninth shutting down what would be known
as greek churches and how they practice
in the italian peninsula either closing
them down or forcing them to practice
the way the latins practice
now there's a whole complicated series
of events as we go into 1053 and 1054.
letters are sent back and forth
eventually pope leo ix sends a
delegation to constantinople part of it
is to
see if they can coordinate against
norman conquerors on the italian
peninsula but part of it is also to make
clear what pope leo ix believes that hey
you have no right to criticize us about
this unleavened bread you don't have
authority over us i am the pope in rome
i have the seat of peter first amongst
apostles and the leader of the
delegation is a particularly proud and
principled individual
when they go to constantinople
patriarch cerullarius doesn't even meet
them essentially is rebuffing their
demands and so because of that that
delegation decides to excommunicate
sarilarius the patriarch of
constantinople the leader of what is now
the most important church in the east
remember the other significant centers
of christianity are now under muslim
rule well in retaliation to that
patriarch cereullarius says hey
you can't excommunicate me in fact i'm
going to excommunicate you and he
excommunicates the delegation
excommunication says i am making you i
am saying you are no longer part of the
church
now when all of these
cross-excommunications are happening
many people probably view this as hey
this is just a power struggle between
folks probably not a big deal but
remember this is over centuries of
increasing division not only do you have
language division you have
in the west you have a leaning towards
these germanic kingdoms in the east they
say hey we we are the real roman empire
you have these issues of philoque and
other things and this
event in 1054
eventually gets known as the great
schism or the east west schism because
it only gets further and further
cemented and they get only further and
further apart
as you get to the end of the 11th
century the crusades begin and we'll do
more videos detailing the crusades where
the western kings start sending folks at
first
on the surface to try to help the
byzantines reconquer land from the
muslim empires
but even when they are successful they
don't give that land back to the
byzantines they actually set up crusader
kingdoms and as they make their way
through the byzantine empire they cause
for the most part a bit of a stir
they're not particularly respectful
through for through the lands that they
pass and it really comes to a point in
1204 where at the end of the fourth
crusade the crusaders actually decide
even though the purpose was arguably to
reclaim land from the muslims the
crusaders decide siege and sack
constantinople itself and take over
now a few decades later the byzantine
nobility is able to retake it but that
kind of cements the difference between
the latin and the greek church known
today as the catholic church followed by
roughly one and a half billion people
and the eastern orthodox church followed
by roughly
250 million people